hello friends and welcome into my office
yes this is temporary but I couldn't
wait to get this epic contest of
scintillating sitcom sassiness out for
your eyes and ears to enjoy from a safe
distance
in today's episode two of the most
beloved sitcoms of all time are pitted
against each other in one corner you
have six friends who love coffee and
living in lavish apartments well beyond
their means in the other corner you have
a bustling office of tomfoolery led by a
lovable idiot who's still figuring out
how to put those kids through college
friends meet the office now a lot of you
out there are probably wondering hey
mark you handsome stud are we counting
the British office - no we're not even
though the British office is so great
it's arguably better than the American
version we're making it a level playing
field and just having friends versus the
American office everybody got that cool
with it good comedy is a place where the
mind goes to ticularly south that's what
she says here's how we're gonna
determine a winner round number one
ratings round 2 tomato meter round 3
characters and then we'll do a wildcard
round to settle the score once and for
all and one of these two shows is gonna
be crowned the second greatest sitcom of
all time trailing only of course Saved
by the Bell
ready to go ok
down one waiting's the Nielsen ratings
are the TV version of the box office
they're what advertisers look at to see
if your show is worth buying time on to
sell deodorant both shows were obviously
big hits with the office being a
juggernaut both abroad in its original
run and then later here in the States
but friends that was a cosmic sonic boom
when it arrived in the mid 90s during
the friends is 10 season run it averaged
twenty three point six seven million
views per week it never did below 20
million viewers in any of its season and
at its height in 1996 it had 30 million
viewers those are I pop in numbers NBC
used to have the slogan if I haven't
seen it it's new to me but we all saw it
like literally every one of us watched
the first time people loved tuning into
the office as well especially in its
rookie season it averaged 11 million
viewers in its inaugural 2010 campaign
and then although the numbers began to
slide down and they went down virtually
every season until it hit its rock
bottom at the final season of 4.2
million viewers per week some of that I
think a lot of that can be attributed to
the advent of streaming that's how fans
like to watch it or maybe they get it on
DVD I remember those why why do we keep
printing this on white yeah but even if
you add in the modern technology factor
friends still takes the turkey friends
also wins an appointment viewing sure
fans loved the show but they really
loved it when it was a crucial episode
or one starring jean-claude van damme
yeah van Damme was in the highest-rated
episode of Friends ever which got 52
point nine million views now some may
claim that it was so popular because
that episode aired right after the
Superbowl but you and I both know it's
because Timecop was there he like
totally changed time friends also won
the finale contest in a landslide so the
last episode of The Office had 4.2
million people watching it the last
episode of
Ren's 52.5 million pairs of eyes that's
good for fifth place of all time in TV
finale history any time you're in the
conversation with Hawkeye and Sam Malone
that's a good day overall the office
averaged eight point five million
viewers for its entire nine season run
and that's very successful by any metric
you want to use in any era but from 1994
until 2004 fans voted with their remotes
and told friends I'll be there for you
week after week year after year what
happened to Ross's monkey we don't care
because you're there for us to going to
sing it I guess I won't sing it Marcel
his owner and his owners five friends
take ram number one congratulations
friends is up on the office one-nothing
round two tomato meter okay so people
clearly watch these shows and they kept
coming back for more but where the shows
you know good let's head out to the
salad bar and take a gander at those
tomatoes I just came up with that it's a
very close game here and it's a
high-scoring affair both shows are fresh
overall according to the tomato meter
and they both most impressive close out
seasons the office edges out friends
overall 81 percent to 78 percent and
both shows feature multiple perfect
seasons yeah multiple seasons with a
hundred percent on the tomato meter
however it wasn't all sunshine and roses
for their combined 19 seasons of work
it's my own fault for using PowerPoint
friends had its low point in its
penultimate ninth season earning a
stinky 20% rotten that year Wow cool
coincidentally the office is second to
last season was also its low point as it
called only a 44% rating both shows
rebounded nicely for their finale
campaigns as friends walked off into the
sunset with an 86% and the office closed
on a fresh 78 percent note job well done
y'all okay know some friends fans are
saying hey remember the 90s we do the
office doesn't so this is an unfair
category the friends I would say take
your 78% overall average and walk away
or else I'm gonna bring up the Joey
Rachel subplot remember he was like
attracted to her if it just didn't work
at all dude chill
the office consistently delivered
quality content that only took a serious
dip when Michael Scott Steve Carell is
character left the show a new manager
came in and the writers didn't really
have a chance both shows scored well and
the tomato meter proves that fans
weren't just tuning in to friends to get
warmed up for Seinfeld and ER they
really love that show man that Thursday
night NBC lineup in the 90s was fire but
the office that's the one that the
critics warm to the most and that's why
it's winning round number two Hey look
at that friends and the office we're
tied at one apiece I'm not superstitious
but I'm I'm a little stiff as' found
three characters in order to have a
great show you need stuff like quality
writing and good direction
I hear lighting is important but if you
want a truly memorable program you've
gotta have characters worth remembering
not Felicia friends has that in Spain I
mean everybody can rattle off the six
names without even skipping a beat and I
think most dudes are some combination of
Ross Joey and Chandler and I think most
ladies would can see that they're a mix
of Rachel Monica and Phoebe each one has
their memorable combination of catchy
lines unique trades and doing something
regrettable but let's not just limit
friends to its poor cast we were spoiled
with memorable role players like Richard
Mona Gunther and Janice and the show
never lacked for star power yet Brad
Pitt Bruce Willis Reese Witherspoon and
tons more made for great cameos
sometimes like full-on subplots during
the ten-year run of the show
oh and did I mention that Van Damme was
in a one-time cuz cuz I like John Clark
meanwhile the office had its zany cast
of characters and role players all
jumbled into one big Vitamix that is the
office and much like friends we could
see ourselves and more importantly our
co-workers in these characters and how
they treated each other in a working
environment friends came along in an
earlier generation and it did lacked the
true feel of New York City in my opinion
the office on the other hand was a true
melting pot featuring all sorts of
people from diverse backgrounds and this
integration was not only reflective of
modern society it added to some of the
comedic value as well the office also
had the distinct advantage of letting
its characters talk to the camera they
could talk directly to us so we got to
intimately know the mental makeup of
Michael Jim Pam Dwight everyone else
even the side characters got their shine
on for my money the funniest person in
the office is creed bratton there's like
a YouTube clip that somebody made of all
of his lines compiled it is fall down
funny and each show had its own marquee
will they won't they relationship yeah
Jim and Pam and Ross and Rachel you need
a memorable romance and look I'll be
fair to the Ross and Rachel storyline it
really had spice at the beginning at the
end but sometimes it felt like we were
just stretching that out for ratings to
me Jim and Pam felt more consistent in
its comedy its drama its authenticity
they were stuck in an office PDAs are
frowned upon
even in Scranton stuff gets pent up and
you can't always express it the way you
want to
we all have been there we all know that
but Ross and Rachel they had all the
freedom in the world to just get this
thing done just get this thing that
knows we're married
people and we're having babies come on
y'all ten seasons let's just get it
together Ross and Rachel y'all took way
too long too many plot twists what
happened to the monkey you know what I'm
gonna take the compressed sanity and the
real feelings of Jim and Pam and while
I'm at it I'm also gonna give the
characters of the office the win in
round number three I find you all
delightful crea to you the most and it's
a total turn-on that's what she said
it's just nice to win one wild card
round social impact oh this is gonna be
a deep breath where do you even start
with this one both friends in the office
hit a cultural nerve when they arrived
and we continued to feel that tingle
until the end of their respective runs
friends came along at the perfect time
for its audience when Generation X had
finally realized oh no you can't just
listen to the Nirvana CDs in your
parents basement while chewing sin
averse and drinking Crystal Pepsi for
the rest of your life
you got to get out and make something of
yourself you got to get out there in the
world you got to go find a job find a
relationship and most importantly find a
coffee shop where you can vent about the
first two things I said to all of your
close friends you didn't think I used
the wear glasses right of course friends
walk that fine line of giving us great
characters with stellar writing but it
transcended just being a thing you laugh
at and it became almost a template on
which young people based their lives I
mean like Rachel's wedding didn't work
out Ross is divorced I want to be a chef
in New York everybody could see
something in that show and glom on to it
so that's your second marriage in two
years yes second in two years third
overall Plus that song I mean do we need
to talk about the theme song who the
Rembrandt says I'll be there for you
it was so peppy and perfectly matched to
the show it effectively ended the
decades-long trend of having an actual
sitcom theme song yeah that's my hot
take is that the Rembrandt's ended
sitcom theme songs because nobody could
follow that after friends it's like any
other sitcom was embarrassed to have one
[Music]
have you heard the two and a half men
one it's just men men men but that's the
whole theme song the Big Bang Theory
it's just like uh much it's not
happening that there was a big bang come
on let's bring back the sitcom Dean no I
do like the one for the office too
[Music]
after friends sitcoms had to pivot and
do something new
not just with the theme song both the
entire structure of the show so when the
office debuted over in Britain
most of us Yanks didn't hear about it
but boy did we sure need it now look the
office in America was not the first show
to use a single camera for the
documentary facade or the confessional
style interviews but newsflash friends
wasn't the first one to use three
cameras in a studio audience so we're
both equal bears beats
battlestar galactica and in the case of
the office millions upon millions of
real-life office workers needed a show
there was not only entertaining but it
also felt like a humorous 30-minute
therapy session everybody who's ever
been in an office for any amount of time
knows uh I got anything with a boss I
got a deal with a co-worker that gets on
everyone's nerves and we all know who
the office brown-nose is the office was
very funny and satirical but it also
reassured us that look we're all in this
thing together and it did that before
high school musical reiterate at that
point the office made huge stars out of
its cast created tons of gifts and
kicked the usage rate of streaming
service and iTunes viewing into another
gear its solidified the single-camera
sitcom as the go-to method for all
future comedy series it may be the
classic three camera studio audience
model became a dinosaur because of
friends during its multi-year reign the
cast of friends was everywhere magazine
covers billboards the bank the cast
famously negotiated their contracts
together to ensure that each one of them
made a million dollars per episode and
the rest of us did everything we could
act more like our favorite friend groups
of pals debated who's who no no you're
the Monica the Rachel haircuts swept the
nation and idiot guys suddenly had a new
pickup line Joey if you please are you
doing the hangout comedy format was
endlessly imitated never duplicated and
my next point may sound like a hot take
but Matthew Perry's Chandler is
criminally underrated for just how
influential he was in the sense of humor
of that generation I'm not great at the
advice can
do you want a sarcastic comment he
brought wittiness and sarcasm to a new
generation of folks and as someone who's
in comedy clubs just about every night
of the week when they're open I see a
lot of Chandler on a lot of my buddies
that are performing on that stage when I
walk outside naked people throw garbage
at me it's really tough to gauge what
was actually the more socially impactful
show but I'm giving friends than odd
here
what's the clincher look at how popular
coffee joints are now as meeting places
for friends to hang out and dish that
that's what we do
first dates a friendly rendezvous a
business proposal help the words I'm
saying right now would have been typed
out on a laptop at a coffee shop if I
could go to my coffee shop right now I
can't so I had to labor here at home but
I guess now I'm missing the point
the Central Perk gang takes the wild
card round and now it's tied up to to to
would you please just and now the moment
you've all been waiting for friends or
the office what's my verdict I'm only
gonna make you wait a little longer
here's a fun game to play with your
friends in the office which characters
would do better in the other ones a show
would the cast of friends thrive in the
office with the quirky Scranton
Pennsylvania characters do okay in the
big city who's gonna do better I'd love
to see Dwight's take on Central Perk
or see how many times Michael Scott
fires and then rehires and then fires
again günther but there is something so
tantalizing about having Chandler Bing
clash with upper management or seeing
Phoebe maybe strike up an office romance
with Dwight I want to see the friends
gang hangout and get that confessional
styled documentary feel at the office so
I'm gonna go ahead and say I want to see
friends in the office and undeclared
friends as
winner in today's eating competition no
God no God please no no look both shows
are cultural landmarks but friends took
the sitcom to new heights and actually
made us invest it in these characters in
a way that I don't recall people caring
about before friends gave us something
to aspire to even if it was just getting
Ross and Rachel to close the deal now I
know that the office helped out a lot of
people because before the office came
around you really just had Dilbert
strips to look at now you had the office
and you had something to let you vent
but look this is all just my opinion now
you actually do get to have your voice
heard vent if you want to comment right
now below and let me know is it France
or is it the office until the next time
I'm Mark Ellis and I'm on a break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]